and after that author jim sleeper
assesses the current state of race
relations in america and discusses the
effect that government has had on the
issue
now elen de baton talks about and reads
from his book how proust can change your
life it's an examination of marcel
proust's book remembrance of things past
which is also known as in search of lost
time and applies lessons from the novel
to modern life
mr de bhutan has written three previous
books he spoke at book soup in west
hollywood california
squeeze in there
good evening i'd like to welcome you all
to book soup tonight we are so pleased
to have with us tonight alain de botten
and he is going to be reading from us
from his new book
which is how proust can change your life
and we will also open up the the florida
questions have a little q a following uh
so enjoy yourself
okay
thank you um this is a rather unusual
book uh
for any of those of you who've picked it
up it's um it's basically a cross
between two things a self-help book and
a study of proust uh the two perhaps
don't really uh aren't really thought of
normally as going together but it struck
me reading proust that he was a man who
was incredibly wise and had many things
to tell us about life and that it seemed
to me that he might be the ideal
candidate for uh for such a study um
i've always been very attracted to
self-help books they're a much
denigrated genre
i think that they're the main problem is
that most of them are very bad however
the idea behind them the idea of a book
that will in some way help to change
your life is is a very attractive one
and um that's why at some point i
decided to put the
the two things together
and ended up with uh this uh this
pristine self-help book perhaps the best
thing to do is to
read from a from a couple of chapters uh
just to give you a flavor of what's
inside the book and um and then perhaps
uh have some questions afterwards so the
book opens with a chapter called how to
love life today and um this really sets
the scene for uh for the prustian book
so um
so here goes
there are a few things humans are more
dedicated to than unhappiness had we
been placed on earth by a malign creator
for the exclusive purpose of suffering
we would have good reason to
congratulate ourselves on an
enthusiastic response to this task
reasons to be inconsolable abound
the fickleness of love the insincerities
of social life the compromises of
friendship the deadening effects of
habit
in the face of such persistent ills we
might naturally expect that no event
would be awaited with greater
anticipation than the moment of our own
extinction
someone looking for a paper to read in
paris in the nineteen twenties might
have picked up a title called la trois
jean
it had a reputation for investigative
news metropolitan gossip and
comprehensive classifieds
it also had a habit of dreaming up big
questions and asking french celebrities
to send in their replies
what do you think would be the ideal
education to give your daughter was one
do you have any recommendations for
improving traffic congestion in the city
of paris was another
in the summer of 1922 the paper
formulated a particularly elaborate
question for its contributors
i quote an american scientist announces
that the world will end or at least that
such a huge part of the continent will
be destroyed and in such a sudden way
that death will be the certain fate of
hundreds of millions of people
if this prediction were confirmed what
do you think would be its effects on
people between the time when they
acquired the aforementioned certainty
and the moment of cataclysm
finally as far as you're concerned what
would you do in this very last hour
the first celebrity to respond to this
grim scenario of personal and global
annihilation was a then distinguished
now forgotten man of letters named arie
bordeaux
who suggested that it would drive the
mass of the population directly into
either the nearest church or the nearest
bedroom
though he himself avoided this awkward
choice explaining that he would take
this last opportunity to climb a
mountain so as to admire the beauty of
alpine scenery and flora
another parisian celebrity an
accomplished actress called bert bovee
proposed no recreations of her own but
she did share with her readers a coy
concern the men would shed all their
inhibitions once their actions have
ceased to carry long-term consequences
this dark prognosis matched that of a
famous parisian palm reader madame freya
who judged that people would admit to
spend their last hours contemplating the
extraterrestrial future
and would be too taken up with worldly
pleasures to give any thought to
readying their souls for the afterlife
a suspicion which was unfortunately
confirmed when another writer already
robert blightly declared his intention
to devote himself in his final hours to
a final game of bridge tennis and then
golf
the last celebrity to be consulted on
his pre-apocalypse plans
was a reclusive mustachioed novelist not
known for his interest in golf tennis or
bridge though he had once tried checkers
and twice aided in the launching of a
kite
a man who had spent the last 14 years
lying in a narrow bed under a pile of
thinly woven woolen blankets writing an
unusually long novel without the aid of
an adequate bedside lamp
since the publication of its first
volume in 1913
in search of lost time had been hailed
as a masterpiece the author had been
compared to shakespeare an italian
critic had likened him to stardal and an
austrian princess had offered her hand
in marriage
though he had never esteemed himself
highly and had once referred to himself
as a flea and his writing as a piece of
indigestible nougat
marcel proust had grounds for
satisfaction
even the british ambassador to france a
man of wide acquaintance and cautious
judgment had deemed it appropriate to
bestow on him a great if not directly
literary honor describing proust as the
most remarkable man i have ever met
because he keeps his overcoat on at
dinner
enthusiastic about contributing to
newspapers and in any case a good sport
proof sent the following reply to la
tazija and its catastrophic american
scientist
i quote from pru's reply
i think that life would suddenly seem
wonderful to us if we were threatened to
die as you say just think of how many
projects travels love affairs and
studies it our life hides from us
made invisible by our laziness
which certain of a future delays these
projects indefinitely
but let all this threatened to become
impossible forever and how beautiful it
would immediately become again ah if
only the cataclysm doesn't happen this
time then we won't miss visiting the new
galleries of the louvre we won't miss
throwing ourselves at the feet of miss x
we won't miss making that trip to india
however the cataclysm doesn't happen and
we don't do any of it because we find
ourselves back in the heart of normal
life where negligence deadens desire
and yet we shouldn't have needed a
cataclysm to love life today
it would have been enough to think that
we are humans and that death may come
this very evening
feeling suddenly attached to life when
we realize the imminence of death
suggests that it was perhaps not life
itself which we had lost the taste for
so long as there was no end in sight
however if due acknowledgement of our
mortality encourages us to re-evaluate
our priorities we might well ask what
these priorities should be and what we
should be doing before the cataclysm
hits us
proust's suggestions the louvre love and
india were not particularly helpful
for a start they were rather at odds
with what one knows of his character
he had never been an avid museum visitor
he hadn't been to the louvre in over a
decade and he preferred to look at
reproductions rather than face the
chatter of a museum crowd his wine a
letter that he that he wrote to a friend
people think the love of literature
painting and music has become extremely
widespread whereas in fact there isn't a
single person who understands anything
about them
nor was proust known for his interest in
the indian subcontinent which was in any
case rather a trial to reach requiring a
train down to marseille a male boat to
port side and then 10 days on a piano
liner across the arabian sea which was
hardly an ideal itinerary for a man with
difficulty stepping out of bed
as for miss x to his mother's distress
marcel had never really proved very
receptive to her charms nor indeed to
those of the mrs a to zed
and it was a long time since bruce had
even bothered to ask if there was a
younger brother at hand
having concluded that a glass of
well-chilled beer usually offered a more
reliable source of pleasure than
lovemaking
but even if he had wanted to act
according to his proposals proust turned
out to have had little chance only four
months after sending his rep his reply
to la tazijan having predicted that
something like this would happen for
years
proust caught a cold and died he was 51.
fortunately proust reflections on how to
live were not limited to an all too
brief and somewhat confusing reply to a
fanciful question from a newspaper
because right up to his death he'd been
at work on a book that set out to answer
albeit in a rather extended and
narratively complex form
a question which was not dissimilar to
the one provoked by the predictions of
the fictional american scientist
the title of the long book hinted as
much
though proust never liked it and
referred to it variously as unfortunate
misleading and plain ugly
in search of lost time had the advantage
of pointing directly enough to a central
theme of the novel
a search for the causes behind the
dissipation and the loss of time
far from a memoir tracing the passage of
a more lyrical age
this was a practical and universally
applicable story about how to stop
wasting and start to appreciate time
though the announcement of an imminent
apocalypse could no doubt make this a
concern uppermost in anyone's mind the
prustian guidebook held out a hope that
this topic could detain us a little
before personal or global annihilation
was at hand
and that we might therefore learn to
adjust our priorities before it was time
to have a last game of golf and keel
over
so that that's the first chapter of the
book which which sets the scene there
are then a host of chapters that
delineate posts more helpful advice um
on on how we should live life it's of
course a paradox that bruce was one of
the great sick men of literature um he
was remarkably unhappy he was remarkably
ill and yet nevertheless there's a
there's a stream of wisdom that comes
from him part of that paradox is
resolved by proof's own theory about how
it is that we ever come to learn
anything in bruce view when we're
comfortable when we're happy
we're not actually in any good position
to start making intellectual discoveries
because happiness doesn't really incite
us to to to make discoveries as a
practical example it's only when our car
breaks down that we're led to think
about how the engine works and if you
apply that idea to um to the sort of
psychological workings of of our brains
then um then that that comes close to
what proof was saying which is really
that that suffering helps us anyway
there are a number of chapters that
delineate proof's thought but i'll dip
into one which is a chapter on
friendship and it's entitled how to be a
good friend bruce had some rather
unusual thoughts about friendship he was
an extremely good friend he had a lot of
friends they all loved him he was
considered a wonderful friend to have
just to give you a a flavor that my
chapter opens with some testimonies of
his friends and they all said that that
bruce was really absolutely fantastic um
one friend of his called josh de laurie
tells us that points to bruce generosity
in restaurants and everywhere where
there was a chance marcel would always
give enormous tips this was the case
even in the slightest railway station
buffet where he would never return
another friend fernan greg tells us that
he proves to always like to add a 200
service charge to any meal he had to
quote him if a dinner cost him 10 francs
marcel would always add 20 francs for
the waiter but he wasn't just generous
uh another friend of his walter berry
tells us that bruce was amazingly
curious
marcel was passionately interested in
his friends never have i seen less
egoism or egotism anyway i could go on
but his friends are basically telling us
that bruce was an extremely special man
who one would want to be friends with
given such generous verdicts it's
surprising to find that proust held some
extremely caustic views about friendship
in fact to find that bruce had an
unusually limited conception of the
value of his or indeed of anyone's
friendships
despite the dazzling conversation and
the friendliness he believed that he
could just as well have befriended a
city as talk to a friend i quote from a
passage in his novel which outlines his
rather caustic approach our friends are
only friends in the light of an
agreeable folly which travels with us
throughout our life
and to which we readily accommodate
ourselves but which at the bottom of our
hearts we know to be no more reasonable
than the delusion of the man who talks
to the furniture because he believes
that this furniture is alive
bruce goes on a number of other very
pessimistic statements he he has and and
bruce capps it all by telling us that
friendship is in the end no more than a
lie which seeks to make us believe that
we are not irremediably alone
it doesn't mean that bruce was callous
it doesn't mean he was a misanthrope it
doesn't mean he never had an urge to see
his friends
however proust was challenging all the
more exalted claims often made on
friendships behalf
principle among these is the claim that
our friends afford us a chance to
express our deepest selves
and that the conversations we have with
them are a privileged forum in which in
which we can finally say what we really
think and by extension be who we really
are
this claim was not dismissed at a bitter
disappointment at the caliber of his
friends
true skepticism about friendship had
nothing to do with the presence at his
dinner table of some intellectually
rather sluggish characters
the problem that prus found with
friendship and with conversation was in
fact far more universal it was inherent
in the idea of friendship and would for
proust have been present if even if he'd
had the chance to share his thoughts
with great geniuses with the most
profound minds of his generation
which in fact he had the opportunity to
do
because in 1922 he both he and james
joyce happened to be at a at a dinner
party at a black tie dinner given at the
ritz for stravinsky jagalev and members
of the russian ballet
joyce arrived late and without a dinner
jacket proust kept his fur coat on
throughout the evening and what happened
once they were introduced was later
reported by joyce to a friend i'll quote
from joyce's testimony of what happened
when he met proust
our talk consisted solely of the word no
bruce asked me if i knew the duke de so
and so i said no
ah hostess asked proust if he'd read
such and such a piece of ulysses prus
said no and so on
after dinner proust got into his taxi
with his hosts violet and sydney schiff
and without asking joyce followed them
in
his first gesture was to open the window
and his second to light a cigarette both
of which were life-threatening acts as
far as bruce's health was concerned
during the journey
joyce watched proust without saying a
word while proust taught continuously
and failed to address a single word to
joyce
when they arrived at pru's flat at the
ramla
pruse took sidney chef aside and said
please ask mr joyce to let my taxi drive
him home
the taxi did so and the two men were
never to meet again
if this story has an absurd side it's
perhaps because of our awareness of what
these two writers could have told one
another a conversation of cul-de-sacs
that ends in nor is not a surprising
eventuality as far as many people are
concerned but it is more surprising and
indeed it's far more regrettable when
it's all that the authors of ulysses and
in search of lost time confined to say
to each other when they're seated
together under the same ritz chandelier
however let's imagine that the evening
had unfolded rather more successfully as
successfully as could have been hoped
what follows is an imaginary dialogue
it's it's the only part of the book
which which has a fictional um angle and
uh it's really a my attempt to try and
imagine what would have happened if if
bruce and joyce had hit it off rather
more successfully
so i imagine proust taking furtive stabs
at an omar american his favorite seafood
huddled in a fur coat
bruce asks mr joyce do you know the duke
de clar montaner choice please i blame
what james leduc what a close and
excellent friend he's quite the kindest
man i've met from here to limerick
proust really i'm so glad we agree about
the duke beaming at the discovery of
this common acquaintance though i have
not yet been to limerick
violet shift leaning across with the
hostness's delicacy to proust
marcel do you know james's big book
proust ulysses natural who has not read
the masterpiece of our new century
joyce blushes modestly but nothing can
disguise the intensity of his delight
violet shift and marcel do you happen to
remember any passages in it perhaps
proust madame
remember passages i remember the entire
book
for instance for instance when the hero
goes to the library i can't resist
quoting and excuse my exxon glare but i
i simply cannot resist
a bane to comfort them the quaker
librarian purred
anyway
that's the end of that section
and yet even if it had gone as well as
this even if proust and joyce had later
enjoyed an animated cab ride home and
sat up until sunrise exchanging thoughts
on music and the novel art and
nationality love and shakespeare there
would still have been a critical
discrepancy between the chat and the
writing between between ulysses and in
search of sorry for ulysses and in
search of lost time would never have
resulted from a dialogue even though
these novels were among the most
sustained and the most profound
utterances both authors were capable of
a point that highlights the limitations
of conversation
when viewed as a forum in which we can
express our deepest selves
so i go on to elaborate on this um this
objection that bruce had to friendship
namely that
with our friends and with it with them
within the medium of conversation which
is a natural medium of a friendship um
it's very hard to get ourselves across
there's something about having to talk
respond in a dialogue which uh which
means that we're frequently unable to
bring out the best of ourselves which is
incidentally why bruce thought that um
or rather asserted that meeting an
author once one has enjoyed the author's
books will always be a disappointment
because when one meets an author one
only meets this person as they're able
to talk in a select moment of time
whereas the the um
a book is is the product of much
elaboration and much thought so he bruce
tells bruce once said in one of his
letters it's true that there are people
who are superior to their books when one
meets them but that's because their
books are not really books so in bruce
when we meet an author whose books we
like we should be disappointed so anyway
i hope i'm disappointing a sufficient
number of you here uh and i hope i'm
doing a good job of that
it feels like it anyway so um but but
that was not the only objection that
proust had um about friendship
another objection that he had was about
his difficulty of being honest with
people uh it's often thought that we can
tell our friends exactly what's on our
minds that friendship's one of these
these these areas in which we can really
express ourselves honestly um but this
does depend on two things and i i go on
in this chapter to comment on why uh on
what these things depend on firstly how
much is on our minds how much we feel
about our friends which if we were to
tell them might actually upset them and
secondly our evaluation of how other
people how quickly other people might
break off a friendship with us if ever
we were to to say things like you have
salad between your teeth or any other of
the more serious uh honest objections
but bruce was not well placed to enjoy
honest friendships for a start he had
far too many true but unkind thoughts
about people
when he met a palm reader in 1918 the
woman was said to have taken one glance
at his hand looked at his face for a
moment then remarked simply what do you
want from me mr it should be you reading
my character but this miraculous
understanding of others did not lead to
cheerful conclusions
i feel infinite sadness at seeing just
how few people are genuinely kind proust
wrote once in a letter and he judged
that most people had something rather
wrong with them
and this combination this this rather
cynical or rather gloomy view of
people's faults was was combined with a
desperate urge to to have people like
proust he was he was incredibly insecure
about um about his own value in society
and he wanted people to like him anytime
he met someone he was very keen that
that he would win this person over he
had a number of strategies one of them
was always to ask people questions and i
go on to outline so if anyone's looking
to to find a quick and easy way to make
friends bruce has some wonderful tips
one of them is that we should always try
and uh and ask our friends questions
about their own lives rather than assert
uh things about about our lives uh
that's just what one thing um
bruce for instance uh pru's friend
george de la ries who was a very keen
rally driver and tennis player
gratefully reported a memoir that he
wrote after proof's death that he often
talked to proust about sport and motor
cars which is rather surprising because
of course bruce cared little for either
sport or motor cars but to have insisted
on turning the conversation to madame de
pompadour's childhood which was one of
bruce's particular obsessions with a man
keener on renault's crankshaft would
have been to misunderstand what
friendship was for and bruce view
friendship was really for for being kind
to our friends rather than being kind to
ourselves
anyway i go on to describe some of these
things um
but there were some rather cynical
approaches to proust's own theories of
of of how to win people over and i'll
i'll just read this little passage
however charming produced manners they
might unkindly have been described as
somewhat over polite
so much so that the more cynical of
proust's friends invented a mocking term
to describe the peculiarities of social
habits his friend fernando greg reports
we created among ourselves the verb to
postify
to express a slightly too conscious
attitude of geniality together with what
would vulgarly have been called
affectations interminable and delicious
a representative target of proust's
crustification was a middle aged woman
called laura heyman a well-known
courtesan who'd once been the mistress
of many distinguished men proust was in
his late teens when he first met and
began to crucify law
he would send her elaborate letters
dripping with compliments accompanied by
chocolates trinkets and flowers gifts so
expensive that his father was forced to
lecture him on his extravagance
dear friend dear delight ran a typical
note to la accompanied by a little
something from the florist
here are 15 chrysanthemums i hope the
stems will be excessively long as i
requested in case they weren't and in
case law needed a greater or more
enduring token of affection than a
collection of long-stemmed plants
prust assured law that she was a
creature of what he called voluptuous
intelligence and subtle grace he told
laura that she was a divine beauty in
fact that she was a goddess who would be
able to turn every man who came into her
vicinity into a devoted worshiper
it seemed natural to end this letter by
offering affectionate regards and the
practical suggestion that
i propose to call the present century
the century of law heyman
lark became proust's friend
was he an extraordinary hypocrite then
the word implies that beneath an
appearance of good will and kindness lay
a sinister a calculating agenda and that
bruce's real feelings for lord hayman
could not possibly have matched these
extravagant declarations
but the disparity may be less dramatic
no doubt proust believed precious few of
his crustifications
but he nevertheless remained sincere in
the message that had inspired and that
underlay them
i like you and i would like you to like
me
the exaggerated scale of social
politeness shouldn't blind us to the
degree of insincerity that every
friendship demands
the ever-present requirement to deliver
an affable but hollow word to a friend
who proudly shows us a volume of her
poetry or her newborn baby
to call such politeness hypocrisy
is to neglect that we have lied in this
local way not in order to conceal
fundamentally malevolent intentions but
rather to confirm our feelings of
affection which might have been doubted
if there had been no gasping and no
praising
because of the unusual intensity of
people's attachment to their verse and
their children
in fact there seems a gap between what
others need to hear from us in order to
trust that we like them and the extent
of the negative thoughts we know we can
feel towards them and still like them
we know it's possible to think of
someone as absolutely dismal at poetry
but actually quite charming
to think of someone as both perceptive
as both perceptive and yet boring both
inclined to pomposity and yet charming
both suffering from halitosis and yet
genial
but the susceptibility of others means
that the negative part of this equation
can rarely be expressed without
jeopardizing the negative part of the
equation
anyway i'll stop it there which is
really that gives you a flavor of um of
what bruce is raising about uh his
objections that he's raising about
friendship and bruce goes on to then to
offer some some very uh handy hints
about how we should behave in social
life and uh and his advice gives gives a
name to the title of the this chapter
which is called how to be a good friend
and uh and and you'll find other
chapters in here on on such things just
to sort of take you through the the
table of contents on
how to take your time how to suffer
successfully proust was very keen on on
suffering successfully perhaps we have a
chance to talk about that
he also tells us about how to be happy
in love which might not if any of you
know
bruce's own love life might seem a bit
of a paradox but anyway he has some
wonderful some wonderful advice on love
and finally tells us how to put books
down which is a chapter on how how we
should um not take books too seriously
but anyway i'll i'll stop it then i hope
that's given you a sense of what what
might be inside and if there are any
questions about bruce or this book i'd
be happy to try and answer them and if
any of you have particularly particular
problems i'd i'd love to answer them and
i'd love to try and second guess what
bruce might have said about them so um
so anyway the the is there any questions
thank you
[Applause]
would i accept a statement certainly i'm
not disappointed
you're not disappointed well that that's
that's very kind but but does seem does
insist that uh the meeting authors
should be a disappointment but
thank you anyway i'll try to support you
later
does anyone else yes
i just thought that i have three of
these books now and i'm giving them as
gifts oh my god
i should give you a commission
what is the the way you said it what you
said the way you wrote your book was all
such good advice to young writers of
whom i know quite a few and they you
know they look the books i don't know i
know about first and i've done this and
that thing
but it's your book that day
what is it about i don't know myself
right um well that's extremely i guess
um so your question is is really what is
it about this book that might be of help
to a young
writer
right um i suppose this is this is there
are many things in this book that would
help someone who's writing because uh
pruss wrote a lot about writing he was
quite he's quite self-conscious about
the process and what makes a good book
uh and of course what's interesting is
that proust draws some interesting
similarities between what makes a good
book and what makes a happy life um in
his view uh good writing is in a way
good living when we're writing well
we're noticing what's important we're
expressing ourselves clearly all of
things which which should really go on
even if one doesn't write books so um
bruce makes some great claims for art
and he talks a lot about art but i think
it would be wrong to say he's just
concerned with with writing i think you
know
a good writer hopefully and a good
writer other things are going right as
well so um but anyway i'm delighted that
it should be of help to to your friends
who are writing so um that's great
are there any other
yes
to me to me
with you uh are
alleviating and writing about not in the
same way
and but the thing that i like about what
you're pointing out and i think i'm
beginning to see it
improved
is
the theme of all of truth is it's not
time it's about awareness
right yes so the point is um
consciousness and awareness right right
i guess so the point is that that um
the the bruce is often
if one if one asks myself what is
talking about often the academic answer
is well this is a book about time and
memory and all these things that seem
rather abstract and i don't if someone
told me this is a book about time and
memory my mind would kind of
go blank i wouldn't know what that meant
um what i've tried to do in writing this
book is to slightly redraw the grid of
how one writes a book about proust most
academic books are written very
beautifully it would have been very easy
for me to write a standard academic sort
of guide through proofs i wanted to
write a book that would be uh that could
be read by people who hadn't read bruce
and also by people who had um but also i
wanted to write a book that would try
and bring out proof's relevance it's a
striking feature of bruce that though he
was living
and writing about uh paris in the late
19th century one doesn't have to be in
paris when it doesn't have to speak
french one doesn't have to have had any
kind of contact with the world that
proust describes in order to be able to
have
a real connection with him um
and i think that's because bruce very
much believed in the universality of
certain uh human situations so reading
proofs one often finds in in kind of
daily life as moments when i think it's
god that's so christian and i think what
one means by that is this is a moment
where bruce would have made one aware of
certain things he would have sensitized
us to certain things and i'm seeing that
now in daily life
i think it's a feature of of many good
books that they help to make us aware of
things about our own world and about our
own life that we wouldn't otherwise have
known it's that paradoxical thing that a
book which is written by someone else
has that strange effect of being able to
tell you about yourself
someone else is able to tell you more
about yourself than you were on your own
able able to deduce and i think
that in that way uh proof's book and and
hopefully my book in the sense that it's
it's r it's a reading of proust um does
bring out um that effect that that great
literature has
are there any
so
yes
well i wonder if you'd answer a question
for me it's not exactly about proofs
because i confess i haven't had a chance
to read your book yet i just discovered
the romantic movement right last week
right and i heard you were coming
tonight and i had to come and ask you
this question right um
what is your opinion and you can answer
as bruce would answer as you would
personally answer however you choose
yeah what is your opinion on the nature
of attraction is it natural or is it
manipulation and by do you understand
what it is okay all right so the
gentleman's just a question about um
what is the nature of attraction uh and
is it natural or is it kind of
manufactured um
huge question let's see where does one
start um
well
what bruce would have said bruce had
some other dark views about love and um
perhaps i can just sort of highlight
some of those um
uh in in this chapter which is called
how to be happy in love
it takes the form of a kind of q a in my
book and um and it just just to give you
a flavor the the cue is did proust have
any relevant thoughts on dating what
should one talk about on a first date
and is it good to wear black
the answer is that advice is scant from
proust and a more fundamental doubt is
whether one should accept dinner in the
first place and i quote from proust
there is no doubt that a person's charms
are less frequently a cause of love than
a remark such as no i'm sorry this
evening i shan't be free
so
bruce would have would very much have
been in in tune with that book um the
rules and which one's advised to not be
free for dinner very often and um and he
has some more i think more sophisticated
reasons for him
for saying that but he's very much he's
very aware of the of the fact that once
one is together with someone uh their
attraction can pale um
one could be more or less pessimistic
about that and
i don't i have fluctuating views on the
subject myself um that i don't really
want to go into but um but i you know i
think it's it's an undeniable feature
that uh very often the moments of
greatest passion are um
when there's insecurity in a
relationship and bruce tells us rather
helpfully um that the cue in this
section of this sort of q a is are there
any secrets to long-lasting
relationships and and the answer is
infidelity not the act itself but the
threat of it for proof and injection of
jealousy is the only thing capable of
rescuing a relationship ruined by habit
and he gives us a word of advice for
someone who's taken the fatal step of
cohabitation i hear a tut in the corner
i hope that anyway it's dark it's dark
advice and one can one can take it or
leave it but anyway bruce tells us and
we have to brace myself for this when
you come to live with a woman you will
soon cease to see anything of what made
you love her at first
though it's true that the two sundered
elements can be reunited by jealousy so
his advice to um to men and women is
that jealousy has a certain adds a
certain spice to relationships i mean
that can make it sound very superficial
does go into this much deeper and it's
all about his theory of how we can
appreciate things and how difficult
it is to appreciate things which are
physically present um in his view the
best way of appreciating appreciating
something is imaginatively it's when we
when we conjures up something in our
imagination that we that we're most able
really to savour it bruce advice
incidentally on going on holiday is that
we shouldn't go on holiday we should
simply go and get from the travel agents
and brochures and then look at the
brochures and dream and imagine and
that's going to be the best holiday
actually to go to hawaii or wherever is
taking things so literally that that we
should that we should desist um so
anyway that's that's bruce advice on on
holidays and in a way on dating
are there any other um
i think there was a question
were you sorry were you trying to ask
um
right the question
the lady's trying to reproduce a number
of times and and has not had any success
and the question is can can she can she
skip and just read my book um i think
read my book anyway but um can you
recruit i don't know let's see i mean i
was doing a
talk show in boston the other day a
radio phone in and lots of people were
calling in and and was sharing their
memories of prusa and it had a very
erudite kind of cambridge atmosphere uh
people were sharing intimate moments
that they'd had with perused on air and
anyway it was very uh almost precious
one could say and uh and and and this
lady called in and she went and she was
on her mobile phone and she said in the
car and she said i'm driving down the
highway and i've got to tell you i've
tried reading proofs about three times
and it's a load of nonsense and i'd just
like all of you listeners out there to
know that not everyone uh has to like
bruce and that um you know one can be
normal and not in prison then she hung
up so that was that was the end there
was no chance of dialogue but i think
you know good for her and and it's true
that um like like all sources of advice
like all like all good books not
everyone's going to like them for often
for good reasons um and uh so i think
one should be very relaxed in the face
of either liking or not liking peruse
that's that's my californian advice for
them
for here so what's his brother said from
your book that the only way to read his
brother's book was to break your leg and
be
that that's right
bruce said that given the length of he
said he said his brother's book was was
wonderful the only problem was that it
took so long to read and that he said
the only way one could read it was eight
have broken a leg or be to have caught
tuberculosis these would be two ways the
tuberculosis is rarer and rarer these
days so that that's a problem so um one
should one should really break a leg so
um so there we are yeah
are there any other
questions on boost or
um
comments remarks i feel like a hog
no please go ahead yeah
uh
do you think
deliberate uh desired and it was a big
book into it right right did bruce have
any deliberate desire to to help other
people i mean that's an interesting
question when bruce was was near the end
of his life uh he said to his maid that
um
sorry joshua preface that bruce father
had been one of the greatest doctors of
his generation he he was an author of
what one today would today describe his
self-help manuals for but physical
self-help um he wrote books on he wrote
books called the hygiene of the body
which was about how to um maintain good
aerobic flow and develop one's muscles
and he illustrated these books and they
were they were very they were very they
were great bestsellers in his day and
when i walked into a bookshop one would
think of proust as as dr proust who was
uh who marcel's father but towards the
end of his life when his father had died
bruce said to his maid
that he wished that he could do as much
for the sick as his father had done that
he with his books could do could help
people as much and i guess that brings
out an interesting therapeutic
sort of ambition that proust had which
was really to help other people um
the question is would he have approved
of my book would he i mean i know people
said you know what would he have said
about your book
well not necessarily too short he would
be extremely polite as we know he would
have done a crucification so he would
have told me it was wonderful etc and
then he would have returned and in his
novel written caustic remarks about this
upstart to writing uh writing these
books so um so i think that's that
that's maybe what he would have said
that's what you said about awareness um
that's what's so important about your
look because it does emphasize awareness
not just in writing but in living and in
reading right the whole thing and just
that one word really
right so highlighting the the word
awareness
yeah i mean
bruce tells us that the books have this
wonderful
he he penned some interesting lines on
how we should approach books he tells us
that books uh are wonderful at making us
more aware of the world and that um a
good book should sort of enlighten us
and alive and us to things um
and and that happened that's happened a
lot with bruce there are lots of
testimonies of people reading prusa for
instance when virginia woolf first read
prus she was absolutely bowled over she
said she talked about how amazing it was
that he'd finally that he'd been able to
put into words sensations that she'd had
but had never been able uh to express
and um
so
so there's that very beneficial aspect
of reading the proof does go on to warn
us that um
a very reverent regard to books a kind
of aura of great writers can often
inhibit us so he tells us that we should
he tells us at one point that um that a
great love of literature should also
should always be combined uh with the
ability to have a good laugh at it he
tells us he tells us in a he says this
in a letter to andre that we should have
a good laugh about literature and i
think he wasn't saying laughing just for
the hell of it i think what he was
saying is that we should laugh because
that laughter suggests a more
spontaneous and natural and uninhibited
response to books which often great
books prevent us from from having so one
thinks of proof in one thinks well this
is going to be very solemn um and that
solemnity is a kind of fake respect or
rather it's a respect that's not going
to
bring us anything and
so that's why that's why bruce says that
we should um
we should always have a certain distance
and a certain um
irreverence towards books
are there any other questions or
is that it so i think that may be it so
anyway that thank you all for for coming
and i hope the proof changes your lives
in some way and and that you're very
disappointed in me so thanks very much
[Applause]
in a minute journalist jacob schlesinger
examines the political history of japan
over the last 30 years
and later jim sleeper author of liberal
racism talks about the state of race
relations in america and analyzes the
way government has dealt with the issue
live in london
do you live in other places
here's a look at two best seller lists